Nos dicen: "Brenda pudo mapear el círculo M en el
círculo N usando una traslación y una homotecia".
Bien, aquí tenemos el centro del círculo M y
este de aquí es el círculo M. Lo primero que
realizó fue una traslación, es decir, su centro
se trasladó de este punto a este otro y, por
lo tanto, al finalizar la traslación tenemos al
círculo por aquí. Después hizo una homotecia con
centro en el punto N, es decir, Brenda realizó la
homotecia con algún tipo de factor de escala para
mapear exactamente el círculo M en el círculo N de
esta forma y todo se ve bien hasta este momento.
"Brenda concluyó: Logré mapear el círculo M en el
círculo N usando una secuencia de transformaciones
rígidas, entonces las figuras son congruentes".
¿Está en lo correcto? Pausa el video y piénsalo.
Bien, vamos a trabajar juntos. Brenda
pudo mapear el círculo M en el círculo
N usando una secuencia de transformaciones,
ella hizo una traslación y una homotecia,
ambas son transformaciones, ¿cierto? Pero cuidado,
no todas esas transformaciones son rígidas,
por eso colocaremos estos signos de interrogación.
La traslación es una transformación rígida,
recuerda: las transformaciones rígidas
son aquellas que preservan distancias,
medidas de ángulos y longitudes, mientras que
una homotecia no es una transformación rígida,
y puedes ver claramente que no preserva
longitudes, por ejemplo, no preserva el radio
del círculo. Ahora bien, para que dos figuras sean
congruentes entre sí el mapeo se debe realizar
sólo con transformaciones rígidas. En efecto,
para hacer el mapeo del círculo M en el círculo N,
Brenda debía de utilizar una homotecia, ya que
los círculos tienen radios distintos. Sin embargo,
su conclusión no es correcta porque estos
círculos no son figuras congruentes.